Next demonstration is another piece of symmetry
breaking,
makes rather different patterns.
Instead of happening in a sandy desert, it
happens in a dish full of chemicals.
It's called the Belousov-Zhabotinsky reaction.
(Bee Zed) BZ reaction if you're English, (Bee
Zee) BZ reaction if you're American.
Belousov was a Russian chemist who in 1956
discovered
that some chemical reactions can oscillate.
They can change from one state to another
and back again repeatedly.
He got very excited about this.
He sent his paper in for publication and the
journal said:
"That can't happen. That's impossible."
"You must have got your experiment wrong,
can't publish it."
And about 10 years later another Russian called
Zhabotinsky
refined the experiment to the point it
was absolutely clear it really did work.
And they said, OK, perhaps you can publish
after all.
I'm going to demonstrate the Belousov-Zhabotinsky
reaction.
Over here I have four chemicals that we have
already mixed up.
Sodium bromide, sodium bromate, sulphuric
acid and melonic acid.
And there's a fifth chemical I'm going to
add which is a colouring,
which will show us exactly how the reaction
is progressing.
Mix them all together.
And it's a sort of brownish colour.
And a good shake and it turns blue, which
is a good sign.
And I pour it into the dish here.
And then I'll give it another shake.
And now it's going brown.
Which is also a good sign.
And now we'll wait for a second and see if
it will do what I want it to do
and in fact it has already started.
Of it's own accord, little blue dots are appearing..
And those dots are spreading and forming blue
patches.
And as the patches grow,
inside them, we see little red dots which
grow
and inside those are blue dots which grow.
And the whole thing just keeps growing and
spreading.
And this amazing pattern appears, like magic,
from nowhere.
But it's not magic, it's symmetry breaking.
The uniform symmetry of the stirred up, shaken
up dish is unstable.
It won't stay that way.
Tiny little bubbles, little specks of dust,
something start out those blue patches.
And once they've started, we just get these
beautiful patterns,
which grow and grow.